hundreds of thousands of people have
died and the global economy is reeling
we're all hoping that scientists find
some way of beating the coronavirus
there are two options use a vaccine that
protects against the infection
and prevents the virus spreading or a
treatment
that stops people dying we need
effective vaccines
in unprecedented quantities and at
unprecedented speed
either would help the world get back on
its feet
world leaders talk about vaccines a lot
vaccine vaccine vaccine vaccine
vaccine vaccines vaccines protect
against infectious diseases caused by
viruses like
polio or measles according to the world
health organization they save up to 3
million lives a year and scientists are
confident they can develop one
for covid19 even though some viruses
are trickier than others for example
there's no vaccine against hiv
or the common cold at the last count the
wh
reckoned there were at least 160
vaccines being developed against the
virus
with some of them in clinical trials in
humans
scientists in japan china the us and
europe are all working
on experimental jabs but there are also
candidates on the list from thailand
egypt nigeria and even kazakhstan
the uk already has two vaccines being
tested on volunteers and they work in
slightly different ways in oxford
scientists are using a harmless version
of a common cold virus
as a trojan horse to carry a snippet of
the coronavirus's genetic material
it infects human cells turning them into
factories that
churn out the so-called spike protein
that coats the outside of the
coronavirus
there is a lot of expectation on waiting
for a vaccine and i generally think that
this vaccine has an extremely strong
chance of working compared to many of
the other technologies that are out
there
at imperial college london a separate
team is doing away with the trojan horse
they're just injecting the rna the
genetic material
from the coronavirus but it instructs
muscle cells to start making the spike
protein
this might sound complicated but put
simply
the human immune system thinks it's
being attacked
it rallies its defenses to make
antibodies and other
killer cells if a vaccinated person
picks up the real
virus the antibodies block the spike
protein
stopping the virus infecting cells and
if any virus does sneak through
the killer cells mop up the infection
that's the theory
but it's hard to do the public would
like a vaccine
today and yet we need to make sure it's
safe
and that it works and that we don't cut
corners
and so it's that pressure of meeting
expectations
but recognizing that if you go
too fast it may come back and bite you
later
90 of vaccines fail some because they
don't
fire up the immune system to make enough
antibodies
others because those antibodies don't
last for long enough
and vaccines tend to work less well in
older patients who need
protection against covid19 the most so
scientists will find it tough and then
there's the problem
of making the vaccine the world needs 8
billion
doses 16 billion if the vaccine needs a
booster
at the earliest a vaccine will be ready
to be used in early 2021
but that's just the first doses health
and care workers are likely to be
front of the queue next in line would be
older patients and those with underlying
health conditions but it would take
months maybe even years
to make enough vaccine for everybody and
that's why some doctors believe
a treatment is a better way of beating
the virus
i mean to me the therapeutic is even
more important than
the vaccine at this point because people
will get better
doctors are raiding the medicine cabinet
for options
some drugs like rem deserve it target
the virus itself it was originally
developed for ebola but it also works in
covid19
speeding up recovery times by four days
but it hasn't
yet been shown to save lives ramdestivia
has a clear-cut
significant positive effect in
diminishing the time to recovery what it
is
proven is that a drug can block this
virus
other drugs target the immune system
some patients aren't killed by the virus
but by their own
immune response which goes into
overdrive the steroid dexamethasone
calms everything down in the sickest
patients it reduces deaths by a
third this drug dexamethasone
can now be made available and we've
taken steps to ensure we have
enough supplies even in the event of a
second peak
scientists are optimistic they can beat
the virus there are no guarantees and
they're bound to be hurdles along the
way
but they'll need to crack it if we're to
get back to a normal life
[Music]
[Music]
you